I guess it's actually 10:15. We should get started.
I would say 15, so
Victor,
I think we would bring up our own slides, right? Or they do it.
We bring them up. If you want to, you just click on your talk and press
start.
Yeah. No worries.
I can help you if you need.
I think I can.
Yeah.
Oh,
my
God
Good morning.
My name is Victor Adelsten, and I'm Director of the Gerstner Center for Cancer
Diagnostics at the Broad Institute,
and I'm pleased to be chairing the session on advances in minimal residual
disease detection via circulating tumor DNA.
Here are my disclosures.
So minimal residual disease reflects a very small number of cancer
cells that remain in the body during or after treatment.
And by isolating circulating tumor DNA with a liquid biopsy,
it's becoming possible to detect MRD that isn't clinically
evident in most, if not all, cancer types.
This could enable therapy response monitoring in real time
and all throughout care
to guide therapy escalation long before progression or
recurrence, when there are fewer cancer cells to treat, and
therefore potentially fewer mechanisms of cancer drug resistance to overcome,
as well as therapy de-escalation, thereby sparing the morbidities of
unnecessary therapy.
In the context of early-stage solid tumors,
this could address important questions around preoperative therapy, such as
how much is needed? Is it working? Is there a pathologic
complete response to therapy? And if so, might it be possible
to omit surgery? Exciting question
groups are looking into. As well as in the postoperative setting,
is additional therapy needed after surgery? Is it working?
Is it safe to stop therapy?
Now we're at this really interesting point in time where the clinical
adoption of ctDNA assays
is somewhat outpacing the evidence for clinical utility, but it's based on
strong clinical validity data and the potential to guide treatment
decisions that would ordinarily be made with
probabilistic measures of residual cancer, whereas we now have the
opportunity with ctDNA to directly measure, is there residual
cancer that needs to be treated?
Yet, as we've also seen from prospective clinical trials in colorectal cancer,
among other cancer types, our ability to detect MRD is
somewhat outpacing our ability to treat it.
And for that, there's another big opportunity for MRD testing, which
is to accelerate the development of new adjuvant therapies to
intercept minimal residual disease.
Where adjuvant therapy trials historically are costly, complex, and
take years of follow-up to determine the efficacy of the
therapy, and in cancer types where there are late recurrences, that can really
take time. If we could use ctDNA testing
to enroll the patients who stand to benefit
and possibly use ctDNA clearance as a surrogate endpoint for
relapse-free or overall survival, we could potentially determine
sooner, with more clear resolution of clinical benefit, by
treating fewer patients, the efficacy of adjuvant therapy, and
therefore bring more therapies that are much needed
to patients.
And we're going to hear about that today in the context of adjuvant immunotherapy,
adaptive trial designs that could intercept MRD.
So today's session, first, Dr. Chaudhry of
Mayo Clinic
will present on state-of-the-art methods to detect MRD
from plasma and surgical drain fluid,
as well as really new exciting methods to infer
spatial tumor ecotypes from liquid biopsies and predict cancer
immunotherapy response.
Dr. Anagnostou of Johns Hopkins will next
describe cutting-edge approaches to detect, characterize, and
address residual disease,
immunotherapy methods
in a neoadjuvant, adjuvant, and metastatic setting, approaches
that could intercept residual cancer.
And lastly, I will describe the ongoing need for higher
sensitivity in minimal residual disease detection, the
factors, both technical and biological, that govern ctDNA
detection, and new approaches we could take to exceed
those present limits.
Now it's my pleasure to introduce Dr. Adel Chaudhry.
Dr. Chaudhry is a professor and vice chair of radiation
oncology at Mayo Clinic.
He's a leader in translational cancer genomics and
has pioneered applications of liquid biopsies throughout the cancer
care continuum.
Dr. Chaudhry, the floor is yours.
Thank you so much, Victor, for the very kind introduction, and it's
my pleasure to be here today.
Great.
So I'll be talking to you today about ctDNA, MRD, and liquid
ecotypes in precision oncology.
So here are my disclosures.So liquid
biopsies have completely changed the game,
and not just in oncology, but taking a step
back in a field that sometimes we don't all think of
as a precision field.
OBGYN.
With cell-free DNA, what we can do in
non-invasive prenatal testing, it's an example of the
power of this sort of technology and what it can do to a field in
just bringing in incredible precision and decision-making.
So when we think about cancer, what are
the features that we can learn from what we
previously felt was a completely informationless
analyte, right? This is the acellular component of blood, right?
When I was in training as a grad student in the
2010s,
we thought there was nothing there, right?
It was everything's in that cellular component, right?
It's all about the PBMCs, and there are some circulating tumor cells in there as
well. But what is in this acellular plasma?
Well, with cell-free DNA, we can measure genomic alterations.
These form the basis for now FDA-approved cancer genomic profiling
assays. We can measure epigenomic changes, right?
Methylation, fragmentation patterns, transcriptomic
changes in cell-free RNA, lipids, proteins, metabolites,
et cetera.
And when this figure was published in 2017 by
Nissan Rosenfeld's group, I remember looking at it, and it
seemed very futuristic to me.
We had data for molecular profiling and
prognostication.
The residual disease era, we were just at the very dawn of that
work from
myself. My colleagues here on the panel were just kind of opening
that up. Early screening, it seemed like it probably wasn't
feasible at that point.
I'm going to talk about MRD detection, and I'm going to talk about how kind of the
field has evolved before I dive into some of the recent work in
our lab.
So just as Victor was saying,
we need ultrasensitive methods. They are required for MRD
detection.
And the reason for this is that when you have high
burden of disease, kind of in a patient with metastatic disease,
you're trying to profile their ctDNA.
You have many copies of ctDNA within cell-free DNA.
So it makes the problem easier.
When you are in a low burden of disease setting, whether it be
MRD or early detection, you fundamentally have
very few ctDNA molecules within your sea of
cell-free DNA molecules. The majority of those cell-free DNA molecules are
being shed from tissues from your body, as well as PBMCs.
It truly becomes not just a needle in a haystack problem, because
a stack of hay has about
80,000 little straws of hay, so it'd be one part per 80,000.
You need more for MRD. You need part per 100,000 or even part per
million. So it becomes like a city of haystacks
almost, right? Finding a needle within that. It's an incredibly difficult problem.
In the early days,
it was exceptionally challenging because we were looking for a single
mutation. Like this is the mutation that characterizes this cancer.
It is this KRAS mutation. We're going to look for it.
The problem was that if you're looking for a mutation, the red one, and you
had tube two of blood,
sequencing even every molecule within that tube of blood,
it would not ever give you that red molecule because it's not even within that
tube. So this was vexing us. It was vexing all of us on this
panel. It was vexing the entire community, until we kind of
happened upon a very practical solution, which I actually apply to
multiple things in my life, which is multiple shots on goal, right?
If we take multiple shots on goal, maybe we can address this
issue, where if we're looking for both the red and the green molecule,
maybe we have a chance of detecting at least one of them.
So myself, kind of other groups around this time
kind of showed that with multi-mutation tracking, you can really
lower that limit of detection because you are not beholden to just a
single or just a small collection of mutations. You can look for more.
So we showed this in our seminal 2017 Cancer Discovery paper,
showing that with CapSeq tracking multiple mutations, we could
achieve ultrasensitive MRD detection.
And up until 2021, using these sort of
technologies, which have a lower limit of detection of about
between part per 10,000 and part per 100,000,
we're able to detect MRD, and that
correlates with worse progression-free survival.
Now, since 2021, a number of groups, including Victor's
group and others, have shown that
when we track even more mutations, we can take this to a
whole another level. I'm showing here nice work from Dan Landau's group, kind of
consolidating on some of that beautiful work he presented at the plenary.
So his group
showed that if you go from kind of 10-mutation capture, which is
around what we did in 2017, take that to the nth degree.
Do 10,000-mutation capture. How do you do that?
Rather than focusing on a panel of just a portion of the
exome, leverage the entire genome.
Look across the entire genome,
track many more mutations. With that, you can start dropping that
detection threshold closer to parts per million.
They show data. This is across multiple cancer types.
I'm showing here the Stage I to III lung adenocarcinoma data
using this sort of approach, this genome-wide
approach for tracking thousands of mutations.
They can detect MRDTwo and a half weeks after surgery, and
that associates with worse survival outcomes.
They then
advanced this further with deep learning, and then with Ultima
sequencing, with deeper sequencing, they're able to achieve lower limits of
detection that go down to the part per million range.
And here I'm giving this table. This is a reference table that I
consider is the 2026 update to that 2021
slide that I showed earlier. The
technologies have really modernized, going from where we were
at around 100 parts per million,
now really improving, starting from whole
exome-based sequencing and tracking less than 25 mutations to
greater than 25 mutations, coming down to 10 PPM, doing
tumor-informed 30X whole genome, bringing that down to
150X whole genome, doing whole genome-based
personalized bespoke panels to target
1,000 plus mutations, and then Victor's work,
Maestro, taking us all the way down to now less than one part per
million. And I think this is a super exciting time.
What are some of the remaining challenges? Well, I'll describe one of them.
One of them is local regional only recurrence.
I'm going to show you one of my patients.
So this is a patient where
after chemo RT, we actually couldn't detect ctDNA
MRD from plasma. Even when we designed a personal panel,
which went down to about a part per million, we were unable to detect
following treatment, and we also missed it at the next time point, too.
We only detected when this patient relapsed, and interestingly, the pattern of
this patient's relapse was a local only relapse.
So the issue is that ctDNA in plasma, it's really
like a measure of micrometastatic disease. It requires some shedding.
And in the absence of that, it can become difficult.
So a question that we asked in the lab is, can we improve the
sensitivity of local regional ctDNA MRD
detection by sampling more proximally than blood?
So, we've been interested in these different biofluids.
We've published on this, and this was actually
a nice article in Jitse that Elsa very kindly invited
us to contribute a review, and this is what we decided to focus on.
Biofluids beyond plasma. And this is the figure from that review.
What we later learned, what we later happened upon
after this review was another biofluid that we just stumbled upon
with my good friend and colleague, Jose Zevallos, who's the chair of ENT at
Pittsburgh, lymphatic fluid. How do you access lymphatic fluid?
Well,
in discussions with our surgical colleague, turns out we can access it from a
surgical drain. Surgical drain that's placed after
surgery for head and neck cancer is
naturally enriched in lymphatic fluid.
It has to be placed anyways. It's standard of care.
It relieves the fluid that otherwise accumulates after
surgery.
It was previously just thrown in the garbage.
So we use it as a practical source of biomarkers for MRD.
We published on this in the HPV positive setting, and then more recently,
January of this year in the HPV negative head and neck cancer setting.
So what we did is we did tumor-informed
next generation sequencing, focusing on single nucleotide variants,
using a panel that targets 700 mutations that
are specific to head and neck cancer.
And we applied this error-corrected tumor-informed approach to both
plasma as well as lymphatic fluid 24 hours
after surgery.
And what we found was that initially, 24 hours
postoperatively, the serosanguinous fluid in the surgical
drain is characteristic of lymph.
It's enriched in lymph-associated proteins.
Also, the cell-free DNA yields are much higher than plasma, and the mean
AFs are also much higher than plasma.
So you really have enrichment of both cfDNA and
ctDNA in this lymphatic fluid compared to plasma.
Lymph ctDNA MRD was associated with worse PFS, so when
we looked 24 hours after surgery, that was associated with worse progression-free
survival, as well as, importantly, worse local regional
progression-free survival. So now we are getting local regional insight
that previously was unavailable to us.
Lymph ctDNA importantly outperformed individual pathology
features, the features that our colleagues use to
inform them to give adjuvant radiation or adjuvant chemo
RT.
We're able to outperform them with lymph ctDNA.
We outperform external extension, perineural invasion, nodal stage,
and lymphovascular invasion.
And lymph ctDNA MRD remained prognostic in patients with low or
intermediate risk pathology features.
Here in patients with N0, we were able to identify certain patients who
otherwise wouldn't be offered radiation, but who still have
poor survival outcomes, who might have benefited from adjuvant RT.
And then patients who are node positive but ENE negative, who otherwise wouldn't
be given chemoradiation, but might have benefited because they're doing
quite poor with radiation alone.
And importantly, lymph ctDNA 24 hours significantly
stratified progression-free survival, while plasma did not at this
early time point.
I'm now going to pivot and talk about another exciting project in our lab, and this
is immunotherapy. And I'll give kind of an overview of where we
started with immunotherapy response prediction and
how I started with some of my visioning for this project.
So I've been really intrigued by tumor mutational burden, which has been
shown to be a biomarker for immunotherapy response.
And in our earlier work, we showed that we can infer
TMB from plasma cell-free DNA from the targeted hybrid
capture panel itself, which makes sense.
The panel is a-... subset of the exome.
So just with simple linear regression, you can infer what's in the whole
exome by interpolating from what's in the subset of it.
We did something similar from urine too, to infer TMB from urine cell-free
DNA.
And then our colleagues at Foundation
Medicine, they showed that blood-based TMB can predict progression-free
survival on immunotherapy, and then they tried to validate this in a
prospective study, but this study was negative.
Yes, TMB is working, but it may or may
not really be working. This is a negative study, very compelling, really
beautiful nature medicine paper.
But are we really moving the needle in terms of being able to predict IO
response with TMB or with the
liquid surrogate blood TMB? I'm not sure.
And so we wondered, can we profile the tumor microenvironment from liquid
biopsy to predict IO response? And this is work with my
dear friend and colleague, Erin Newman at Stanford, brilliant computational
biologist.
We put together a study to try to do liquid
biopsy of the tumor microenvironment, and we did this very rigorously.
We started by doing spatial transcriptomics on 100
tumors across 10 cancer types in four spatial transcriptomic
modalities. We learned that there are these co-associated cell
states in the tumor microenvironment that are very stereotypical,
such that
different patients with different cancer types, those cancers cluster
better based on the spatial ecotypes in terms of their
prognosis compared to within the cancer types themselves.
We developed a Google Maps of sorts of where these spatial
ecotypes live within the tumor microenvironment.
They showed that they have prognostic as well as predictive significance, and then
we translated that to plasma cell-free DNA methylation
using an advanced binary neural network model, and we showed that we could use
that to predict immunotherapy response.
So I'm showing you this because for a long time this has been a
pet peeve of mine. We, including me, have been using this word liquid
biopsy, but is that really accurate?
With liquid biopsy technologies, with ctDNA, we're only looking at malignant
cells. When a pathologist looks under the microscope, they're seeing much
more. There are all these microenvironmental cells that have been invisible to
us in the liquid domain.
So
it felt like something that we had to address.
How can we really capture a greater portion of liquid
biopsy from plasma to go beyond just the tumor cells?
So we started by doing spatial transcriptomics and
very simply, you divide up the tumor microenvironment into an inner
margin that's sitting right next to the tumor cells, an outer margin that's sitting
outside of that, and then the outer stroma.
I'm showing an example here of melanoma with Merscope and then
breast cancer with 10x Visium.
And then what we saw was interestingly, we see
that these spatially defined cell states form a continuum
reflecting the physical distance between the tumor and the
outer stroma. So we're seeing really a shift in the tumor immune cell
states and stromal cell states as you go from right next to the tumor out to the
outer stroma. And not only that, we see that these
spatially conserved neighborhoods of cell states, they also
shift as you're going from the inner core out to the outer edges of the
galaxy.
These spatial ecotypes, as I was saying, they have distinct geographic
localization,
and they consist of spatially co-localized cell states.
And interestingly,
spatial ecotype one has fibroblasts.
Spatial ecotype three has fibroblasts. Spatial ecotype four has fibroblasts.
Five, six, seven, and eight. But these are different fibroblast cell states.
The cell states that are living right next to the core are different than the ones
that are living right outside, all the way outside in the outer edges of the
stroma.
So
we're seeing here these co-localized cell states,
and we're seeing them from spatial transcriptomics data.
I'm going to focus here on spatial ecotype seven and four, which I'm going to show
later are associated with IO response versus resistance.
Spatial ecotype seven is sitting right there, right within the tumor
cells, right in that inner margin area, while spatial ecotype
four is hanging out there in the outer stroma.
We then,
for practical reasons, we developed Spatial Ecotyper to
quantify spatial cellular ecosystems from bulk RNA-seq
data. I'm showing here that it's faithful to the ground
truth spatial transcriptomics. So we can now deconvolve these
spatial ecotypes from bulk RNA-seq, and this now lets us
analyze across TCGA, analyze across 17 carcinoma
types and melanoma across TCGA,
and then importantly, also access these IO studies.
So these are 15 different studies of immunotherapy across four
different cancer types with pretreatment tumor tissue that
RNA-seq was run on. So we're able to secondarily analyze that with
Spatial Ecotyper, and when we do that, we see that spatial ecotype
seven and eight are strongly associated with immunotherapy response and
outperform other biomarkers. While spatial ecotype four is strongly
associated with immunotherapy resistance and outperforms other biomarkers.
We then developed a binary neural network method in order
to translate this to the liquid cell-free DNA methylome
space in order to infer these spatial
ecotypes from liquid biopsy cell-free DNA methylomes.
Using this binary neural network model, I'm going to show you one of our
validation data sets. There are multiple of these, and I invite you to look at
our paper in "Nature" that's going to come out in two weeks.
But here what we did is we did spatial transcriptomics on the tumor
tissue as well as paired plasma, and you're seeing here an overall
correlation between the ground truth tumor Visium data as
well as the normalized rank spatial ecotype levels in plasma
cell-free DNA methylomes.Spatial ecotype 7
is associated with response. Spatial ecotype 4 is associated with resistance.
So there's a yin-yang relationship there. Seven is high, four is low.
Four is high, seven is low. We see that in plasma, we see that in ground
true tumor tissue as well. So here we've developed for the first
time ever a non-invasive platform for spatial biology.
So we then move this into two validation sets.
I'm showing one here. The other was
in the poster that I presented on Sunday.
So focusing here on 80 patients with melanoma
with response that was scored, we measured that spatial
ecotype 7, 8, and 4 showing those, and ctDNA.
Seven and 8 are associated with response, 4 is associated with resistance.
Ultrasensitive ctDNA is not associated with response or resistance.
So 7 is associated with response as well as improved survival,
4 is associated with resistance and worse survival.
And this importantly is pre-treatment.
So prior to IO, we're already able to measure
non-invasively what is happening in the tumor microenvironment and
portend survival outcomes. Again, spatial ecotype 7
forecasted immunotherapy benefit and spatial ecotype 4
forecasted immunotherapy resistance.
And this held up on multivariate analysis while PD-L1 and
TMB did not. And I'm showing here where we see the
future going, where we can track these
liquid spatial ecotypes serially,
perhaps even in an MRD setting. And I'm showing here a
patient who we thought had progressive disease, but turned out that they had
pseudoprogression. And you see spatial ecotype 4 falling and
spatial ecotype 7 rising, really portending this
ultimate response over a year earlier
than it actually happened, at a time point when we were totally vexed because we
thought they had progression, but they actually had pseudoprogression.
Recently, we've extended this to non-small cell lung cancer.
I'm just showing the pilot data here.
So this is
data showing that in lung cancer we also see that these spatial
ecotypes associated with immunotherapy response versus resistance,
and that in the liquid space we're able to predict immunotherapy response versus
resistance, including in neoadjuvant therapy when PD-L1 and
TMB are not able to perform. And I think this could give us incredible
precision, especially in the neoadjuvant space where decision-making
skills are really lacking because it's unclear should the patient get
neoadjuvant and go to surgery, or should they come to me to get chemo RT?
So in summary, liquid biopsy cell-free DNA analysis using
ultrasensitive methods enables MRD detection and treatment response
prediction. Sampling cell-free DNA local regionally from
surgical lymphatic fluid in head and neck cancer can boost ctDNA
detection sensitivity and risk stratify low and intermediate-risk patients.
And cell-free DNA methylation analysis using spatial
transcriptomics-derived AI enables liquid biopsy of the tumor
microenvironment and prediction of immunotherapy response.
So I'd like to thank my lab members, I'd like to thank my collaborators,
and for this work, especially Aaron Newman at Stanford and Jose Zevallos
at Pittsburgh, my funding sources, and most importantly, patients and their
families. Thank you very much.
You just have three minutes for questions.
So
if anyone has questions, please step up to the microphone, or you
can submit your questions in the meeting app, or using the
QR code here up on the slide.
Hi, Chaudhry.
Thank you for your talk. I'm from Mayo Clinic,
earlier from Rochester, now in Jacksonville, Carty Therapeutics.
My question is regarding
how can these technologies help the Lynch syndrome patients?
Because
you cannot... This is about MRD, but even if you can talk
about the early detection for small bowel cancers
as well as urothelial cancers,
uterine cancers in Lynch syndrome patients.
No, it's a great question.
There's a lot
of exciting work happening in the early detection space.
And there, I think some of the principles that make that unique compared to
MRD is that we don't have tumor information.
Someone is coming in, even if they have predisposing risks, we don't
know what that tumor will look like.
And so the field has moved away from
mutation-based approaches and towards epigenomic approaches, such
as using methylation.
But would be happy to talk to you more about that.
Thank you, Adil. Excellent talk, and also
congratulations to your "Nature" paper.
Thank you.
I am very curious about the cfDNA profiling of the
ecosystem.
If
the
predictability of the response to
immune checkpoint inhibitor
depends on the
tumor fraction in the cfDNA. So
if there is any correlation between
the tumor fraction in the cfDNA you analyze
and its predictability for ecosystem.
It's an absolutely excellent question.
And we're doing that experiment right now.
We're seeing
settings where we're able to measure these liquid ecotypes
with accuracy and precision, even when ctDNA
measured with CAP-Seq is undetectable.
So there's something happening, and there are examples of tumors where the
TME may be much larger than the tumor core itself and
more accessible to the bloodstream for shedding.
But in terms of the formal LOD analysis, that's something that we're doing as we
speak.
Thank you.
I think we have time for one more super quick question.
Oh, I'll make it real quick. Dan Faden from Mass General.
Awesome talk. Thanks for sharing the data.
I think you hit on a really interesting topic.
I'm a head and neck cancer surgeon clinically, and neoadjuvant immunotherapy is
having a really big impact right now.
And I'm curious,
in the data you've generated, have you looked at serial time points on
neoadjuvant therapy or only the time point before you start neoadjuvant
therapy?
It's a great question. So far, we've only looked at the time point before,
but we are looking to do this serially as we speak. Yeah.
Yeah. And can you hypothesize as how these signatures will change
once you start therapy?
Yeah. I
hypothesized that as you're getting closer and closer in a responder, you're going
to see a tumor microenvironment that's amenable to response, kind
of boosting those liquid spatial ecotypes over
time up until the point of an exceptional response, and vice versa for resistance.
But purely a hypothesis. We need to do the work together. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Chaudhury.
Next, I'd like to introduce Dr. Anagnostou. Dr.
Anagnostou is a professor of oncology at Johns Hopkins
University.
She is transforming precision immuno-oncology
using liquid biopsies, among other methods, to characterize mechanisms of
treatment response and resistance, and guiding the
immune-based interception of MRD. Dr. Anagnostou.
Thank you so much, Victor, for the introduction, and thank
you to the organizers for the invitation to present
to this session today. Really excited to share our recent
work on liquid biopsy approaches to detect, characterize, and address residual
disease. So very quickly, these are my disclosures.
And I think Adil wonderfully set the stage in terms of cell-free
DNA biology and what it is we are measuring
in liquid biopsies. But what I will
predominantly talk about is the clinical
value of these approaches. And I'm going to focus
on the value of liquid biopsy approaches in
residual disease detection in the early stage setting, as well as
the value in monitoring therapeutic response in the metastatic setting.
And what I would argue from the get-go is that it is
incredibly important to use liquid
biopsy residual disease approaches to dissect the heterogeneity of
pathological responses in the early stage setting, as well as
radiographic responses in the metastatic setting.
And if we do that, we need to do that to be able to
rationally design ctDNA adaptive clinical
trials that will lead into clinical benefit for our
patients across settings and across cancers.
So Adil already reviewed this, but I'm showing you
here the
several alterations that can be detected in a sensitive
manner in liquid biopsies, and I'm showing you this to show you
that I'm going to be focusing today on sequence alterations.
But of course, there is a plethora of additional alterations that can be detected
that include translocations, amplifications, deletions, larger
copy number
losses and gains, as well as cell-free DNA fragment,
physical fragment properties.
And in addition to certainly capturing the
genetic footprint of cancer by ctDNA and cell-free
DNA approaches, cell-free DNA molecules retain the
epigenetic footprint that is reflective
of lineage and tissue of origin. And what
we're showing here is additional alterations that
can be detected by liquid biopsy approaches.
And these
span a large number of cell-free DNA features
that have to do with plasma and ploidy,
nucleosome occupancy, coverage, and occupancy at
transcription factor binding and initiating sites, repeat
elements, and of course, fragment size
distributions. We heard a lot in this meeting, we're going to hear
in the next talk as well, in terms of the value of potentially
integrating those analytes in an
attempt to further increase the sensitivity of detection
of ctDNA.
Now, again, Adil very nicely went through the challenges
with liquid biopsies. One of them certainly being
the sensitivity of detection and the limit of detection,
and introduced the breadth versus
depth
challenge. What I'm showing you here is simulation
analysis showing the
limit of detection or improvement of limit of detection,
shown here as parts per million, with an
interrogation of an increasing number of
alterations. And of course, from a very oligo, single mutations or
oligo mutation-based approach now expanding to thousands of alterations.
And these approaches have allowed us to
detect ctDNA in a very sensitive manner.
What we're showing you here on the right-hand side is how does this translate in
terms of in the differential limit of detection of clinically
used liquid biopsy approaches. Started with the
very first ones introduced, tumor-naive gene panel NGS that
Adil
reviewed as well,
and then the improvement in limit of detection as
we move towards tumor-informed approaches, be it
bespoke or non-bespoke. I'm going to talk a little bit about this.
Now down to ultra-sensitive, tumor-informed,
whole genome sequencing-enabled liquid biopsy approaches
that I think are going to be very clinically meaningful.
Now, let's look at how the
concept of
minimizingTechnical error,
if you will, applies in the context of two technologies that
have been recently developed. So what we're showing you here is
a tumor-informed whole genome sequencing-enabled approach.
This is data from the TracerX data, where you can appreciate the
clear benefit going from an oligo mutation-based approach
to whole genome sequencing-enabled
detection, and our ability to detect the majority of early-stage
cancers. And this was truly enabled by the ability
to look for 2,000 or so alterations or SNVs across the genome.
And certainly, there's additional ways to suppress
error and distinguish noise
from true signal. What we're showing here on the
right-hand side is the implementation of interrogational
phase variants. And so you can imagine that if you're
looking for variants that occur in cis on
the same DNA molecule, of course, this can further
suppress error rates in
MRD liquid biopsy approaches.
So we're very excited to see the implementation of these approaches.
The question though I'm going to pose is,
more broadly, are tumor-informed approaches feasible?
And I think the verdict is out there, but just to
say that the previous approaches rely on
a bespoke configuration where
comprehensive genomic profiling of the tumor is done
initially, followed by development of specific panels that are
then applied in the liquid biopsy assay.
So what I'm showing you here is slightly different, still a tumor-informed
approach, but it's non-bespoke. So there isn't
a step where an individualized panel is
developed on a per-patient
basis. Rather, what is done here is we are detecting a
credible
set of single nucleotide variants.
This is, again, after whole genome sequencing that enables the
interrogation of thousands of SNVs across the genome.
And the suppression here, the increase in sensitivity
comes from a machine learning approach that is embedded that pretty much
differentiates noise from bona fide cancer signal,
together with a
comparison with a non-cancerous cell-free DNA reference, and this data
was
presented earlier on in this meeting.
And of course, the question is, of course, we're achieving analytical
sensitivity, but how do we do when we're looking at clinical
samples? And so what I'm showing you here, which we also presented
earlier during this meeting, is the
performance of this approach in two clinical trials of neoadjuvently
treated patients with gastroesophageal on the left and mesothelioma
on the right. And what you'll appreciate is the
clear
increase in terms of detection across time points
during the neoadjuvent period until the time of surgery with the
whole genome sequencing tumor-informed approach.
Now, there are certainly
further improvements in technology.
Adel mentioned the implementation of
PPMseq or paired plus/minus strand
sequencing here.
And so this is proof of concept and
optimization analysis from the same assay that I presented to you
previously, but now with incorporation of
PPMseq, and what you'll appreciate is
the clear improvement with version two
of the assay down to a few
parts per million. So again, very excited to
see the implementation of these approaches into clinical
practice. Now, Adel made an
important point, and I want to emphasize this and show you data from different
settings that in addition to tumor fraction, we're also capturing
biology. So this is data
that we presented earlier in this meeting, where
we took the cohort of patients with gastroesophageal cancer
treated with neoadjuvent immune checkpoint blockade, where we showed you
ctDNA dynamics,
and ctDNA detection across different time points.
And we paired that with matched RNA sequencing of
tumors from the same patients, and then asked the question, if we look
at cell-free DNA tumor fraction high patients
versus low, do we see any differences?
And what we captured here, which is very clear and important,
is that in patients with a high cell-free DNA tumor fraction, we're
capturing cellular turnover, as you can appreciate, with enrichment
in cell cycle progression and proliferative
gene expression programs in these tumors.
In addition to the technical challenges with liquid biopsies, I want to
very briefly mention some biological noise
challenges that we're facing. Now, important to note here that this is not the
case with tumor-informed approaches.
This is the case only when we're considering
mutation-based, tumor-agnostic, hybrid capture for the most
part, next-generation sequencing approaches, which is what we typically use for
genotyping in clinical practice and monitoring the metastatic setting.
So,
a good fraction of mutations detected by liquid biopsies are not
derived from
tumor cells.
And so they're derived by clonally expanded hematopoietic cells, and we're
showing you here the
confounding effect of such mutations.
If all mutations are considered together independent of cellular origin, then any
association between mutations in two driver genes that we're showing here,
P53 and SMARCA4, they're obliterated.
So it's truly important to distinguish the cell
origin of variants, and this is
work that was done in the lab and presented in this meeting as well,
where we
developed a machine learning model to practically distinguish
variants in plasma-onlyplasma only next generation sequencing
based on origin, and this was done by machine learning integration of
patient-level, gene-level, mutation-level, and
mutant fragment-level features that, as you'll appreciate here,
allow for a very sensitive distinction
between tumor-specific and clonal
hematopoiesis-derived mutations.
Now, we talked about the challenges very briefly.
How about the opportunities? I'm very excited about this, and so
Victor also presented this beautiful slide at the beginning,
showing the potential clinical value of liquid biopsy approaches in
terms of capturing residual disease and intervening upon residual
disease.
But are we there yet?
So I think
we're getting there, but it is very, very important, in addition to
analytical sensitivity, to understand the clinical
sensitivity of ctDNA minimal residual disease.
So this is the question that we asked, and practically here, did a
reanalysis of perioperative
and neoadjuvant and adjuvant clinical trials for
which liquid biopsy readouts have been reported and asked the
question, if we look at concordance of ctDNA
residual disease or minimal residual disease, depending on the time point that this
is determined, and the clinical endpoint of the trial,
what is it we learn? So here, this is a dense slide, but the
studies are shown on the left-hand side and the ctDNA
observational studies on top, ctDNA interventional studies at the bottom.
Then we're sorting by endpoint, be it pathological response, be it
recurrence-free survival, the time point, and cancer type.
And the concordance, the legend for the concordance is here.
What we've learned from this study is certainly that the concordance
between ctDNA negative status and response,
these are the dark blue bars, this is high.
So that's great. But what is concerning
is the salmon bars, which are patients with ctDNA negative
readout that do not attain response.
And you can appreciate across studies, and it didn't matter what time point, what
setting we looked at, that salmon bar is actually quite
sizable. Right? So what that means is, in terms of the clinical
implementation of ctDNA MRD, is that we really truly need
to see the clinical sensitivity of the ultrasensitive MRD approaches to be able
to make decisions for our patients.
There is a lot of examples of clinical validity,
right? I'll show you some of our group, where here we looked at
ctDNA residual disease readout for patients with
operable gastroesophageal cancer treated with neoadjuvant immunotherapy.
And of course, ctDNA clearance or undetectable ctDNA
was associated with better outcomes.
I want to point your attention to the
bottom right. Here, these are patients that did not attain a
pathological complete response, and we saw that this group was indeed
heterogeneous. So we can better prognosticate patients,
and predict outcomes in the very heterogeneous group of
non-path CR based on ctDNA residual disease.
And going back to biology, it was truly beautiful to see that
tumor regression and tumor and ctDNA
elimination that we're showing on the left-hand side was reflective of
neoantigen-specific T cell responses. Right?
So you see regression of tumor fraction
together with
emergence, practically, of the specific anti-tumor immune
response.
We wanted to bottleneck these approaches,
and
use a truly low tumor mutation burden
setting. And so the data here is from a clinical trial
of neoadjuvantly treated patients with early
stage mesothelioma. Of course, mesothelioma harbors a very low tumor
mutation burden, so any tumor-informed approach that
relies on the breadth of genomic loci is
bottlenecked. Here we applied the whole genome sequencing tumor-informed
approach that I presented previously.
And what we found very interestingly is at every single time point that we looked
at, but specifically at the time prior to surgery,
after administration of the neoadjuvant component of
therapy, ctDNA
persistence was certainly associated with inferior clinical
outcomes. And so even in
these more challenging settings, certainly there is value
to ctDNA minimal residual disease.
But are we there in terms of the clinical implementation?
So we need to
put together the studies to answer the question of what is
the clinical sensitivity of ctDNA MRD, and this is what
we did together with Charu Aggarwal, and this is in the context of the
ECOG-ACRIN Cooperative Clinical Trials Group, where we put
together a trial. This is the TICTACTOE trial to
specifically address the concordance of ctDNA MRD four to
six weeks after definitive therapy for patients with
early stage non-small cell lung cancer to determine the concordance with
outcomes. And I think this is an important study because
it will allow us first to understand how
should we be defining ctDNA MRD. Is this
measured once? Do we need a technical replicate in that time period?
Should we be thinking about monitoring?
How do the ultrasensitive tumor-informed approaches
perform in this setting? And from an assay
development, it's quite exciting because you can
imagine we could use this platform to potentially develop
or validate a tumor-agnostic approach.Let
me show you a few trial designs, and Victor mentioned this at the
beginning. So,
how would we intervene if we had the answer?
So if we had the assay and we knew exactly how to intervene, how would we do it?
So here I'm showing you a concept that we're working on, and this is, again, in the
context of early-stage non-small cell lung cancer after
neoadjuvant immuno-chemotherapy, after curative intent
surgery, where we're selecting a high-risk population.
This is the patients that do not attain pathologic complete response and/or
ctDNA MRD positive at the landmark time point, four to six
weeks after curative intent surgery.
And these are the folks that are then randomized to standard of care or
experimental combination therapy targeting MRD eradication.
That is one way to do this. I'm happy to talk about additional trial designs, but
this is something that we are working on.
Certainly, there's a lot of value in ctDNA,
optimized or guided therapy de-escalation.
This has been very nicely shown in the dynamic trials.
We're showing you here dynamic two and stage two colorectal cancer, dynamic three
on the right for stage three colorectal cancer, where a
ctDNA-guided
adjuvant therapy de-escalation was non-inferior compared to
standard of care. This was shown in stage one.
It nearly missed
the pre-specified thresholds for stage three, but I think
this shows the value of ctDNA guided de-escalation, and
certainly this is very important in terms of avoiding toxicity, in
terms of cost-effectiveness or whatnot.
So maybe in the next minute or so, I will
touch upon residual disease in the context of metastatic
disease, which I think is important because this is
closer to clinical implementation, if you will.
And of course, there are specific trends of ctDNA
dynamics that are reflective of clinical responses.
Here we're taking the example of metastatic non-small cell lung cancer
treated with immunotherapy, specifically pembrolizumab.
And so we define ctDNA molecular
response as clearance of
ctDNA levels three week-- six weeks, apologies,
after pembrolizumab administration.
Now, lots of
discussion in terms of how do we even define molecular response in the
metastatic setting. Is it two time points? Is it one time point analysis?
What I'm proposing here, and this is from analysis that
we've done and presented at this meeting as well, is that a
single time point analysis, we call this landmark
molecular response, six to nine weeks after immunotherapy
administration provides credible sensitivity and
specificity, but also allows us to evaluate
pretty much all the patients,
and as such, is a very feasible approach in terms of
capturing immunotherapy response.
So I'm going to show you the BR36 trial just as
a proof of concept in terms of how are we translating
these lessons into ctDNA adaptive
trial design and just show you the first stage of this trial, which was
specifically designed to test the clinical sensitivity of
ctDNA molecular response. And so you'll appreciate there was a good concordance
between resist overall response and ctDNA molecular response.
There were exceptions,
certainly within the partial response category,
with folks that did not attain molecular response the same,
even within disease progression.
And it is the molecular ctDNA molecular response that got it right in terms of
predicting long-term outcomes. And so this is now the
ctDNA interventional part of the study
where we are making decisions in terms of therapy optimization for
patients with metastatic non-small cell lung cancer that start with immunotherapy
pembrolizumab alone.
And based on ctDNA readout at six weeks
on pembrolizumab, and upon persistence of ctDNA
and resist non-PD, they're randomized to either continuing pembro
or step-up approach or escalation with pembro chemo,
primary endpoints PFS and OS, and we think that this is a study that
could establish ctDNA molecular response in the
immunotherapy setting. So
here's my take-home
points. You can read the slide. I'm just going to just highlight two points.
The one being that it is important to consider the
analytical and clinical sensitivity of the assay based on its
intended use when we are
trying to implement these assays in clinical practice.
And we truly need to work together to do
more ctDNA adaptive clinical trials to
prove clinical validity, which is--
and utility. We have validity. Clinical utility, which is what we need.
So with that,
I will end and thank the folks in the molecular oncology lab that did
the work, our collaborators worldwide, and thank you for your attention.
Happy to take questions.
I'll ask the first question.
I'm curious
how close we are to being able to
determine pathologic complete response from a liquid
biopsy and realize a future where
patients who do have exceptional response in the preoperative setting
may be able to forgo surgery
Yeah. That's a very insightful question.
And I think with the emergence of ultrasensitive approaches, potentially the ways
that you're going to talk about, which is attenuating clearance of
ctDNA, we would be able to accurately
predict pathological response. It was very interesting
data that was shown at the immunotherapy clinical trials plenary yesterday in
MSI-high tumors, where you could
potentially, by administering dual immune checkpoint blockade,
could forgo therapy, and ctDNA can be used as a readout in
this context. I'll tell you, in one of our
trials
with
neoadjuvantly treated gastroesophageal cancer, we saw
exactly what it is you're describing, which is this very early clearance.
That was after two doses, I believe. This was day 28.
And so there are these super responders, if you will, and I do believe you
can capture those with ctDNA approaches and potentially forgo
some leg of what comes next in terms of therapy.
Wonderful. Well, thank you so much.
I think there's a question.
Oh, is there? Sorry, the spotlight.
It's okay.
We have time for one quick question. Thank you.
Great presentation. So from your perspective, what are the barriers
the industry and academic collaboration could
address bridging the gap from analytical sensitivity towards
enhanced clinical sensitivity?
Yeah, that's a great question. Thank you for bringing this up.
To design a ctDNA adaptive trial, you have to know what assumptions you're
going in with, and one of them is: what is the
concordance between ctDNA MRD positivity and then the
outcome that one is interested in capturing, be it pathologic response or
recurrence-free survival or whatnot.
And at least in non-small cell lung cancer, we do not have that answer, and that
was precisely the motivation for us behind designing the Tic-Tac-Toe
trial, because we need to get these numbers in the context
of ultrasensitive, and I think it's ultrasensitive
tumor-informed approaches. I mean, that's what we have right now.
We need that information to design a ctDNA adaptive trial
in the early stage setting. So this is the challenge that we're facing right now,
but I'm very hopeful because we're doing the trials
to actually get these answers.
Well, thank you so much, Dr. Ana Nastou.
Now, I will be the last speaker in this session.
So following the exceptional talks from my colleagues on
the state-of-the-art in methods for MRD detection and
driving these towards clinical application, I'm going to focus on the factors that
govern sensitivity and what we can do to exceed
present limits.
Here are my disclosures. I am a co-inventor of the Maestro MRD test,
which has been licensed to Exact Sciences, now Abbott.
And I'm also a co-founder and advisor to AmplifierBio, that's commercializing the
first priming agents for liquid biopsies, and I'll speak about both of these in my
talk.
So liquid biopsies could transform cancer care,
but higher sensitivity is needed to detect the earliest stages of cancer
and minimal residual disease, and to enable tumor molecular
profiling from blood for most patients.
If we think about what's limiting sensitivity, it's insufficient circulating tumor
DNA.
A stage one cancer with a billion cells in it may only yield
less than a cancer cell worth of circulating tumor DNA in a blood
draw. And under those circumstances, there will be
incomplete sampling of the tumor genome, where these different
colored mutations from the tumor wind up in different blood tubes,
as we've seen.
And assay technology alone cannot solve this problem.
For comprehensive genomic profiling, clearly it's a problem if the whole
tumor genome is not in the blood tube.
If there's a clinically actionable mutation over here that's not being assayed, no
amount of sequencing will uncover that.
But it's also easy to see how sampling more cell-free DNA could address
this challenge. Indeed, we predict here in advanced non-small
cell lung cancer, where the sensitivity is still
66% for EGFR mutation detection here in the
RF3 trial. If we had 10 to 100 fold more cell-free DNA,
we
believe we could improve detection up to 90 to 95%.
Now, for minimal residual disease detection,
assay technology can partly overcome insufficient ctDNA, as we've
heard, by assaying for any and many mutations that may be drawn in a tube
of blood.
And there are now many great MRD assays, a subset listed
here, spanning tumor-informed bespoke, tumor-informed non-bespoke, tumor
agnostic, that all operate under similar principles, looking for sparse
signals in blood.
Now, despite tremendous progress, MRD detection is still
not a solved problem.
ctDNA has proven an incredibly specific marker of MRD,
even at part per million levels. But false negatives are a real
problem, even with next generation tests,
and it's due to the biology. There are biological limitations that constrain
detection.
In addition, beyond simply detecting MRD, we want to be able to profile
it to inform therapy selection, what to target when the cancer is coming back.
And when the cancer is coming back, there's not yet a lesion that you can go and
biopsy. So how do we get this information in?
And that's where to date, comprehensive genomic profiling tests are largely
used in advanced cancer, but we want to push those into
earlier stages and really be able to profile
MRD.Now,
there's a lot to be excited about, a lot of great data,
but we also need to be careful about representation of MRD
data. We sometimes see claims of near perfect
longitudinal sensitivity
based on any amount of time points testing positive being counted towards
detection for that patient, and that risks overstating
ability to detect MRD.
We should be focused on landmark sensitivity, which is what needs
improvement.
And we also need to be careful as assays get closer to the clinic
and physicians are acting on the results of tests
just to realize the limitations of existing studies, where at
times we find studies could be enriched for higher stages or grades or early
relapses or conclusions drawn from limited number of patients who
relapsed. And we just need to be careful that those limitations are
understood as we advance these assays clinically.
In addition, I believe we need better standardization of MRD tests.
We often hear
impressive claims of what different assays can detect, but we
rarely stop to ask with what likelihood,
under what circumstances, and how this will vary in real patient samples.
So let's remember, these are highly personalized
assays for heterogeneous markers in individuals whose
cell-free DNA yields vary.
We should be using LoD95. This is the lowest
ctDNA level in blood that can be detected with 95%
likelihood, recognizing it varies per sample and
ideally reporting it per sample.
For FDA-approved comprehensive genomic profiling assays,
this is what's used, LoD95.
And we can see it very clearly trends with the amount of cell-free DNA
tested. That is, the limit of detection can be six times better
if you have six times more cell-free DNA.
And it's basically a sampling probability.
It's what's the lowest fraction of ctDNA in the body, in the
bloodstream, where the odds of drawing the threshold
number of molecules required for detection is greater than
or equal to 95%, given the amount of cell-free DNA
that's been sampled, or even better yet, that's been sequenced.
And it's super easy to predict with a binomial model.
For MRD, we've heard about breadth and depth and how that affects limit of
detection. And I just want to unpack that a little further.
If we have a test that assays, say, 100 mutations in 10 nanograms
of cell-free DNA, that will be about 3,000 haploid genomes.
We have 10 times 3,000 is 300,000 informative
molecules that have been tested. There's no way to detect...
Well, it's unlikely to detect one part per million
with that amount.
And if we assume, say, two or more mutations need to be detected
to call MRD,
the LoD95 with a binomial model would actually be 16 parts per million under
those circumstances.
But another critical parameter is the background error rate for the markers being
tested. That even if you had 10 million informative molecules,
if the background error rate is not below one part per million,
you won't be able to resolve ctDNA at one part per million.
And with advances in error-corrected sequencing, this is increasingly becoming the
biological mutation frequency, which varies by mutation
context and can be as low as 10 to the minus six all the way down to 10 to the
minus eight for ultra-low noise mutations.
Now, there's a lot of excitement and promise for multi-omic approaches and
multi-analyte approaches, and I believe these will improve detection,
but where they're going to be most useful is in the intermediate range, not the
ultra-low ctDNA levels, just because the background errors are
higher, and it's just not possible to leverage those
to overcome these detection challenges.
Now, there are multiple technical and biological constraints then on MRD
detection.
Each MRD assay has a different upper bound on breadth and depth.
Each patient's tumor has a different tumor mutation burden
and subset of low noise mutations that permit ultrasensitive
detection. And in some patients, it's a very small subset.
And if you only have, let's say, 100
ultra-low noise mutations that are tracked in those 3,000 genomes, you only have
300,000 informative molecules tested for those ultra-low
noise mutations. You can't detect below one part per million.
Even though you technically have the sufficient error rate to get there, you don't
have enough molecules to reach that level of detection.
Each sample also has a varied cell-free DNA yield, and that constrains depth.
So basically, breadth times depth is inversely proportional to LoD95, and you can
predict LoD95 easily with a binomial model.
So the reality is LoD95s vary widely,
10x, maybe even 100x in real patient samples,
and contributes to the false negative problem.
It may also explain transient detection and clearance.
If for instance, you detect ctDNA after surgery,
but then
four weeks later,
there's less cfDNA in the blood tube, the limit of detection of the
LoD95 may not be as good. The ctDNA level may still be 35
parts per million, but now it may appear as though it's cleared.
And so this is a very critical parameter to understand and
contextualize if there's a negative
result.
So how to exceed present limits? First, I think we should push assay technology
to the biological limit for each patient and sample.
But beyond that,
I think we're going to need diagnostic drugs that allow us to sample more cell-free
DNA from the body and ultimately increase the proportion that's cancer
derived.
If we could sample 10 to 100 fold more cell-free DNA,
it would basically be
like tracking 10 to 100 fold more mutations per patient.
And so in the situations where maybe there's only 100 ultra-low noise mutations,
now you can imagine instead of 3,000, you have 300,000,
times the 100, and that's 30 million.
Now you're at a level where you can harness those ultra-low noise mutations and go
super deep.This could have the effect of making
first-generation tests as sensitive as next-generation tests, pushing
next-generation tests to their best limits of detection, but still
recognizing those will be bounded by the mutation frequency in normal cells.
That's just a hard limit that we can't otherwise exceed
until we change the ratio of ctDNA in blood.
In addition to MRD detection, we have comprehensive genomic profiling, and
that's what we're also excited about being able to do that, in the context of
MRD to inform
targeted therapy and interception early.
Now, to increase the tumor fraction in cfDNA, again, I think could allow us
to exceed that hard floor on the background mutation frequency in normal cells,
enable higher sensitivity with simpler assays, and also
detect the earliest stages of cancer MRD, do molecular profiling of
those, do risk stratification, avoid over-treatment, and all those
sorts of things we'd want to do in the long run.
Now we've developed some different NGS technologies.
CODAC and Methyl CODAC, for instance, can allow us to resolve
biological mutation frequencies as low as three in 100 million
using single NGS read pairs, basically by linking both strands of each DNA duplex
together in a platform-agnostic manner.
And we've thought about this for tumor-informed non-bespoke tests, and I think
there's a lot of
advantages to these sorts of approaches.
But we did the math and realized
we could only do low PPM detection in patients with the highest tumor mutation
burden.
And,
basically, we concluded it'd be better to track most of the low
noise mutations to very high depth rather than more high
noise mutations to low depth.
That's challenging given the excess of normal cell-free DNA in blood.
But we developed an approach called MAESTRO, which uses short allele-specific
oligos under optimized thermodynamics to enrich rare mutations apart from
the massive excess of normal cell-free DNA in blood to detect those with
substantially less sequencing.
Here you can see MAESTRO converts low VAF mutations to high VAF mutations to
detect ctDNA at or below part per million levels and with high specificity
in thousands of patient-unmatched samples.
And this is enabling, as we've heard, the potential to
monitor therapy and determine efficacy early.
Here in early-stage triple-negative breast cancer, as early as week three on
therapy, we could resolve responders from non-responders.
And half of the non-responders had tumor fractions in blood that dropped below the
limits of many first-generation ctDNA assays, which would have
appeared to have cleared.
In DLBCL,
a relapsed/refractory disease on CAR T therapy by week one on therapy, we can see
differences. In head and neck cancer with Dan Faden, we can see
one to three days after surgery, associations with future relapse or
death, and with 71% of samples below this 100 PPM
threshold of many first-generation tests.
And there's one patient without recurrence who actually was slow to clear by day
seven, had a history of fatty liver disease, and the liver, as I'll get to, is
important in cell-free DNA clearance, and I think might actually explain that
observation.
And just as a side note, Dan, by the way, has a great HPV
sequencing assay, for those of you who are interested, HPV DeepSeq
for HPV positive cancers. And in HER2-positive
metastatic breast cancer,
we see potential at the year one landmark to discern patients with exceptional
response, real-world PFS greater than three years, where all those were
ctDNA negative, whereas many of the conventional responders were
still positive. And Heather and colleagues are interested now in could
we deescalate therapy in those patients who have extraordinary responses.
So Exact Sciences, now Abbott, is turning MAESTRO
into the OncoDetect v2 assay, which will launch this year.
They've kindly allowed me to share some data slides with you today,
showing here detection down to 0.25 parts per million with strong
linearity.
That v2 outperforms a currently commercially available v1 assay at low parts
per million.
And importantly, the LOD95 benchmarking, which we don't often
see for every test out there, but here we can see as a function of
panel size and input, in some early benchmarking, the
effect that tumor mutation burden, et cetera, might have on detection
across different cancer types and samples.
In multiple clinical pilot studies, we're seeing this improves detection.
In esophageal cancer, we've seen
59% of samples detected pre and post-op below that 100 PPM
threshold of many first-generation assays.
And actually, 30% of samples were below 10 parts per million.
We saw high PPV and NPV for recurrence in the first post-operative plasma
sample as well.
Now, in terms of the impact sampling more cell-free
DNA could have on a test like OncoDetect v2,
we did some modeling. I mentioned simple binomial models can predict these
associations, and you can see from the esophageal study, the original samples,
most were
at one part per million at limit of detection 95, but span
from 0.3 to 30, right? And that depends on tumor mutation burden and cell-free DNA
yield. If we had 10 to 100-fold more cell-free DNA, we could
drive all the LODs
below one part per million. In fact, most would be at about 0.1 part per million,
and possibly even lower.
Now for comprehensive genomic profiling, we could also imagine taking that same
library and running a therapy selection test on
it. And here you can see
more cell-free DNA could drop those limits of detection
from what are currently in the high range due to these are the levels where
the whole tumor genome is in the blood draw, down to that occurring now all the way
down to about 10 parts per million and be able to do that on a greater
fraction of samples in the context of early-stage
disease.So how can we do this without sampling 10 to
100-fold more cell-free DNA without drawing 10 to 100-fold more
blood?
Together with Sangeeta Bhatia, Chris Love at MIT, and talented members of our
labs,
we thought maybe we could give an injection before a blood draw that could briefly
slow the clearance of cell-free DNA from the bloodstream and allow it to
build up and collect more, before quickly returning to
baseline. And the idea of giving an injection before a blood draw,
or rather giving an injection to improve a diagnostic is not new.
In medical imaging, this has been done hundreds of millions of times.
It's just hasn't been done before for liquid biopsy.
So we've come up with two distinct approaches so far.
One is an empty nanoparticle that distracts Kupffer cells of the liver and keeps
them from consuming nanoparticulate cell-free DNA.
The other is an Fc silenced antibody against double-stranded DNA that shields it
from nuclease digestion and cellular uptake.
And both have shown order of magnitude improvements in ctDNA recovery in
mice and have many favorable characteristics for clinical
translation.
For instance, here you can see a dose-responsive effect of the antibody on the
fraction of the tumor genome that can be sampled from a blood draw.
Here, again in mice. And with more molecules bearing each
mutation being represented, which is important for mutation calling,
discerning those true tumor mutations from CHIP, et cetera.
We see a lot of key features of cell-free DNA are retained, nuclease occupancy
patterns, methylation. We see better recovery of DNA's hypersensitivity
sites that are ordinarily underrepresented in cell-free DNA.
And we have a new preprint, which has some expanded characterization
and insights.
So how do we envision this integrating into the clinical workflow?
Well, just like I mentioned, imaging scans are ordered with or without
contrast. We envision a future where liquid biopsies will be
ordered with or without priming. And the effect of that would
be getting 10 to 100 blood tubes worth of cell-free
DNA from a single blood draw.
And we've started a company, AmplifierBio,
which is bringing this to the clinic. A first-in-human trial will start next year.
And Amplifier has already shown a hundredfold improvement
in ctDNA recovery in preclinical models with
optimized versions of these agents and humanized versions as
well.
Meanwhile, to understand the effect that sampling more cell-free DNA could have
clinically,
we had a unique opportunity to analyze higher volumes of plasma from
patients with glioblastoma on personalized tumor vaccine study.
And found just having three to fivefold more the median
amounts of plasma that are typically obtained
in the clinic actually doubled our ctDNA detection rate using
MAESTRO in this population. And so this suggests that
in a low-shedding cancer type, where tests may hit sort of that
biological limit on LOD with mutation burden and amount
of cell-free DNA, that if you could increase that sample, you can go even
deeper. And beyond boosting
total cell-free DNA,
we are also thinking about ways that we can enhance the shedding
and increase the ratio that's cancer-derived.
And we think that that could have a big effect, along with developing
formulations which can be administered through subcutaneous and oral
routes. I think for early detection in particular, that will be important.
And just very briefly, some new data here.
We have a targeted liposome now, which is showing a twentyfold
stronger potency and the ability now to modulate cell-free DNA clearance
in the tumor microenvironment, which we believe is the first step towards
enhancing shedding.
So in conclusion,
insufficient circulating tumor DNA remains the major barrier for liquid
biopsies across early detection, MRD, and comprehensive genomic
profiling. And there are limits to what assay technologies alone
can achieve. I think we're starting to realize we're hitting those limits.
We have a test, MAESTRO, and soon to be launched,
OncoDetecV2, which is really pushing that to the limit
for each patient and sample, tracking as many low noise
mutations as we can to the greatest depth that we can to enable
detection at or below part per million levels.
But there's still limits on the amount of cell-free DNA and the tumor mutation
burden of a cancer. And so
this is where we have
strategies now to modulate the recovery of cell-free DNA from the body,
and we believe putting those together with tests like MAESTRO or
other tests as well, we think there's opportunity to improve many
downstream liquid biopsy approaches with more total cell-free DNA.
And ultimately, we believe diagnostic drugs will be needed to achieve the
next level of detection for liquid biopsy to exceed what are
otherwise biological limits. It's done all the time for medical imaging.
We believe it's time we have these sorts of approaches for liquid biopsy too.
So have a great team to acknowledge and would be pleased to answer any
questions. Thank you.
Perhaps I can start with a question, until folks come to the microphones.
Really fascinating work. I was wondering whether you can tell us a little bit more
in terms of potential toxicity of the attenuating
agents and interactions with potential medications that the patient may be on.
I'm thinking statins, for example.
So is there potential for liver toxicity? Have you looked into that?
What are your thoughts?
Yeah. So
conceptually,
an Fc silenced antibody has attributes that bode
well for safety. Effectively, we're minimizing those
interactions with the immune system, reducing ability to interact with complement,
with Fc gamma receptors, and possibly even shielding some
of the aspects of DNA that may otherwise
affect immunogenicity. And so
we have that.
The agent is given, not for therapeutic purposes, but for diagnostic purposes at
these single points in time when we want higher sensitivity and is
designed like a contrast agent to be short acting.Provide this
boost to then return to baseline very soon after.
So we believe it has a lot of the characteristics that will bode well
for safety. But
Amplifier now is advancing the agent through what'll be
GLP tox and all the appropriate steps to
formalize that.
Okay. That was a great talk.
Okay.
So very informative.
Since you hinted to the fact that there are many
millions cells in the tumor, whatever, when it
recurs, and
then it's very few
cell-free DNA to be found.
Do you have an idea what cells are sort of selected to shed
their DNA in the circulation? Are there studies when you have
some, in the sequencing study, something that can be compared
from a biopsy or a surgical specimen to have an
idea of what really is selected?
Yeah, it's a great question. And perhaps I could give
my perspective, so then use this as a nice transition into the panel discussion,
because I'd love to hear what my colleagues think as well.
Throughout the years, there's been efforts to associate clinical pathologic
features of tumors,
Ki-67, proliferation rate, stage, grade, et cetera.
And generally, there's an association with tumor volume and how much
ctDNA is shed, but there are other anatomical barriers and factors that
affect release and possibly even the immune cell interactions,
these ecotypes within the tumor. Ellen Heitzer's group has a nice preprint
dissecting some of those aspects of ctDNA release in tissue
versus blood, and
I think there's substantial potential to try to understand that
better, and doing so may inform potential approaches that we could do
to convert what would otherwise be low-shedding tumors into high-shedding tumors
to improve detection. But perhaps I
take a moment, and I think I'll sit down, join my colleagues here, and then we can
get to your question.
Oh, please. Yeah.
Yeah, I can quickly add.
I completely agree with Victor, and
there are certain tumor types that
stereotypically are just lower shedders, kind of renal cell carcinoma being an
example. So I mean, there are certain tumor types that
are higher shedders, there are others that are lower shedders for biological
reasons.
And just, I think I showed this one slide from the
gastroesophageal cohort where we can truly, in doing matched tumor
analysis, capture cellular turnover in the patients
with a high tumor fraction, cell-free DNA tumor fraction.
So for sure, cells that undergo cell cycle very
quickly, and then go through apoptosis, they die, release their contents.
I mean, these are the ones that we're capturing
in the circulation. Going back to your wonderful work
in terms of being able to capture not only
signals from the cancer cells themselves, but their interactions and probably
non-cancer cells, the tumor microenvironment.
This is something that we are learning in terms of being able to capture
biology and potentially signal that comes from immune cell subsets.
And we've seen this as well by doing whole genome
sequencing analysis and looking at transcriptional states that can be
inferred, where we can actually capture interferon gamma alpha responses in the
context of immunotherapy. So there is more information
past that
certainly tumor fraction, and sometimes the signal is diluted
if there's too much of an immune cell component.
Oh, yeah. A nice talk. And I think that the
idea of priming has a great potential also in multi-cancer
detection. So have you ever tried the
priming
in multi-cancer detection? For
example, you can just try
the priming for patient with
false negative
MCD result. Yeah.
Yeah. Great question. I'll answer that,
and maybe broaden the scope related to
the prior question about determinants of shed.
More broadly, hematological malignancies is where the MRD field
really got its start, and MRD testing is standard of care,
and used to guide therapeutic
decision-making,
especially in leukemia, for instance.
In myeloma, it can be done from
biopsies in addition to blood, and in lymphoma, a little bit more
challenging, but also feasible from blood.
I think the promise ctDNA offers is, again, the ability to
generalize beyond,
say, looking for
RT-PCR-based assays in leukemia, and have more of a
pan-cancer approach. And so I think conceptually,
a priming approach could, just like it can, it's interfering
on clearance, briefly attenuating that, and
we think that just like ctDNA is a generalizable analyte, we think
that could be generalizable to multiple
cancer types. But would welcome any comments from my colleagues about sort of
the relationship of
MRD in
heme malignancies to solid tumors, and any lessons or
takeaways from that.
Thank you. Perhaps I can start by saying that the FDA has been very interested in
this, and I think not too long ago, there was a
multiple myeloma-based workshop, where, of course, in this
setting, the minimal residual disease configuration,
characteristics, thresholds, they're much more established.
And I think the lessons learned from that
can, I think, be translated to the
solid tumor setting
whereI think in the context of multiple myeloma, what
was proposed is a 10 and the minus five perhaps
threshold, right, to determine minimal residual disease.
So we're certainly learning, and some of these lessons
are applicable to the solid tumor space.
Yeah. I completely agree, and I think we're kind of at the precipice
of something very exciting, kind of, again, learning from
our heme colleagues in the heme MRD space.
Kind of in a heme malignancy, and when you can do flow
cytometry to detect minimal residual disease, you also have the
ability to immunophenotype that disease and kind of get insight
into how to treat that MRD. And now, I think we're right at the
precipice of actionability. Just like Elsa was
saying, there's so much information packed right
within that oncogenomic information that's packed
in there, and we're just being able to now uncover that in order to not just
detect MRD, but to also effectively ablate it.
That's such an insightful comment, and I just want to say before we get to other
questions, I just want to say the fact that
therapy resistance is not always genomically
wired. It's epigenetically driven, and this is what I think
we're capturing by methylation, whole genome sequencing or
whatnot, that will allow us to then intervene and
potentially circumvent resistance in ways other than
just tracking tumor fraction. So understanding the biology, which is real
exciting.
Thank you for the wonderful talk. So my question is, there has been
some discussion on what is the best time to take
the samples to check the ctDNA levels, because there are certain
factors that can temporarily increase the ctDNA levels in
cell-free DNA
like certain procedures that may temporarily increase biopsies
or
sometimes radiation-induced
tissue damage that can increase the ctDNA levels temporarily.
So what are your thoughts on this? What should be the safe window that we
could apply for collection of these
samples?
I'm happy to begin.
In our experience, we've seen different therapies have
distinct effects on ctDNA levels in blood, for
instance. That study I showed in early-stage
triple-negative breast cancer,
upon chemotherapy,
chemotherapy reduced the fraction of ctDNA in both the
responders and non-responders, possibly inducing tissue
damage and other
contributors to this total cell-free DNA pool.
Whereas in immunotherapy, in that CAR T
study I showed,
we did not see that reduction across the board.
We actually saw
the responders show a reduction in ctDNA fraction,
but the non-responders actually just stayed stable
. And that surprised us a bit
in a number of ways. One, you could think
if the immunotherapy is working, you might expect...
Or just like if the chemotherapy were working, you might expect to
see some increased shed from the cells that are dying.
But it's a complex picture how ctDNA is
produced, and the interaction between tumor cells and immune
cells, and clearance in the microenvironment, and bottlenecks that
with the short half-life of cell-free DNA as well.
It's really complicated to think about there being a single time point
after therapy induction where you could just all of a sudden get
a boost. And in the literature, studies have been mixed on this point.
I think there's been some encouraging data that maybe radiation could have an
effect, and, of course, would defer to Adil
on this, but
the effect was modest and
inconsistent at the time point. So it wasn't clear that there was a singular time
point that you could just collect blood after therapy and have
better detection.
Yeah. I completely agree. When we started the
field, I think
we were very conservative in sampling three months after the end of
treatment. And three months, and that got moved to one month, and then
more recent studies we are seeing,
Dan Faden's excellent study, for example, really just ultrasensitive ctDNA
on post-op day one, and that really nicely stratifying
relapse-free survival.
One general principle is that the ctDNA half-life is short, and so
it really is an excellent real-time biomarker.
But there are certain caveats, as Victor was alluding to.
With radiation, we've seen that after
a fraction of stereotactic radiation, there's a spike in
ctDNA. It's a little inconsistent across studies.
Even in my own hands, I've seen some inconsistency there, but I have seen 24
hours after an SBRT fraction in some patients there being a
spike such that that wouldn't really be a good MRD
landmark, for example. So
long story short, I think
a week is probably where we are in our current
setting if we were to go across different therapy types.
But that is moved back quite a bit from a month plus where we
were, let's say, a few years ago.
What I would say here that there's at least the
conceptual concern of dilution versus tissue
injury, right? So where you mentioned a
tumor-derived spike, but then with tissue injury, you just see a lot
of cell-free DNA that it's maybe lung-derived, but not lung
cancer-derived. So I think in thinking about
designing trials or intervening clinically on what time point to intervene
uponWe tend to be a little bit
more distanced from
tissue injury, and if it's surgery, typically four to six weeks.
So it does depend on the setting, right?
Adult, also reviewed metastatic setting, perhaps in the context of therapy, as
Victor was saying. In the context of curative intent
surgery, typically four to six weeks post-operatively.
The question you're posing is extremely important, and we haven't answered
it as a field because we haven't done enough technical replicate
analysis, right? So if I was to measure ctDNA MRD twice
on that day, right? So what would be the response?
If I was to determine ctDNA molecular response in the metastatic
setting six weeks after pembrolizumab twice, or with one day
difference, does that change the clinical validity or the
concordance, which is what it is you're asking.
We don't have clear answers on this.
The best paper I can think of, and again, this is using
older ctDNA MRD technology,
is a study, I'm forgetting the authors, but it was called the DYNAMIC study.
It wasn't T at all. But it was actually a lung cancer study that was
called DYNAMIC. And after lung cancer surgery,
they measured one day, three days, and then one month.
And one month was able to stratify progression-free survival very well.
Three days was able to comparable to one month, but one
day was not able to. So I think from that, I think I agree.
I think that's the best study I can think of.
Again, that's using older technology, but probably not within the
first few days. Again, Dan Faden's excellent study may be
challenging that paradigm.
Probably a week is enough, but conservatively, four to six weeks.
Great. Well, we are at time.
Thank you, everyone, for joining us for the session this morning.
Hope you have a great rest of the meeting.